Lady Gaga loves to shock us with her outrageous getups.
At Sunday night's VMAs, there was this Alexander McQueen number with a gold mohawk.
Then there was her prickly black leather ensemble with a Statue of Liberty-inspired crown.
And then came this juicy getup.
As Gaga accepted the award for video of the year,...
...she asked Cher to hold her meat purse.
And we all realized just how raw her dress was.
Last week, Gaga wore a meat bikini on the cover of Vogue Hommes Japan.
Guess that was just a taste of what was to come...
...'cause she caused a feeding frenzy backstage when she pulled this stunt.
When Ellen Degeneres grilled her about the outfit,...
...she said she meant no disrespect to vegans and vegetarians.
"But, if we don't stand up for what we believe in...
...and if we don't fight for our rights pretty soon,...
...we're going to have as much rights as the meat on our own bones.
And I am not a piece of meat."
So, what did PETA have to say about the butchery?
They say Gaga's lucky she wasn't crawling in maggots.
Nice.